they're truly one of the greatest ever
ever put on a United shirt you were
lucky to have it lucky to watch it show
him a bit more respect
yeah I'm not surprised uh I'm surprised
perhaps at the speed that has happened
um but I'm not surprised that Cristiano
is now leaving Manchester United it
seems by Mutual consent obviously I
doubt that would have happened without
the interview so it's had huge
consequences but I think that he will be
happy that he's now free to pursue his
career elsewhere with a club which
hopefully will serve him a bit more
respect than the current ownership and
Executives at Manchester United showed
him peers um how much contact have you
had since that interview last week did
you have an inkling about timing or
where he might go
no I've been in daily contact with
Cristiano just to make sure that he's
okay with everything as it's all rolled
out it's entirely how he wanted it to be
he wanted to have his say he knew what
he wanted to say he's the greatest
football player that's ever played the
game he's the biggest sporting icon in
the world he just passed you know half a
billion Instagram followers this week
and he's at the World Cup so it's the
biggest possible stage with the biggest
sporting icon at the center of a huge
drama he's used to that he's used to
drama and I think that he was just fed
up with the way he's been treated simple
as that and Manchester United I mean if
the fans are happy they've lost
Cristiano Ronaldo they need their their
minds checking because he remains to me
one of the best strikers in the world
leading for another welcome to Piers
Morgan uncensored well it's not been a
quiet few days that's it the goat has
bolted Cristiano Ronaldo out at Old
Trafford after using his bombshell
interview with me on this show just at
the record straight about what was going
on at the club and his concerns well
tonight I'm going to set the record
straight myself on Cristiano Ronaldo and
on that interview because one week on is
still making Global headlines
breaking news Cristiano Ronaldo's time
at Old Trafford officially over
Manchester United saying that they have
mutually parted ways effective
immediately all of this stems from that
explosive interview with Piers Morgan
Cristiano Ronaldo has left Manchester
United with immediate effect it follows
a TV interview with Piers Morgan where
he claimed he felt disrespected and then
that explosive interview that he had
with Piers Morgan saying those uh very
hurtful things about Manchester United
and after an explosive interview with
Piers Morgan the writing seemed to be on
the wall
like I said it was explosive well this
Show's been at the center of a true
Global story and that story really is
only just beginning because minutes
after Ronaldo confirmed he'd leave
United by Mutual consent the Glazer
family who own the club confirmed by
looking to sell American Family bought
Manchester United for 1.3 billion
dollars in 2005. now they may get four
times that amount and if that sounds
like good business well it is for them
but that's precisely why United fans
have such a problem with the glazes who
loaded United with debt and presided are
a steady but massive decline on the
pitch they seem more concerned about
selling shirts and shares than winning
Trophies the opposite of what English
football should be about this is what
Ronaldo himself said to me about the
glazes
the owners of the club they listen they
don't the glazes the glazes they don't
they don't care about about the club I
mean
professional sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion
the funds are they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
so did Ronaldo's condemnation of the
glazes force the issue of the years of
protests by supporters you can judge
that for yourself when the biggest
superstar in the club's history calls
out mismanagement at the very top how
could their position be tenable
supporters and Club Legends like Roy
Keane and Gary Neville have also slammed
the glazes never even called on Ronaldo
to use his status to put them under
pressure stand up now and speak he wrote
this summer The Club is in crisis it
needs its leaders to lead Ronaldo's the
only one who can grab a situation by the
Scruff or the neck exclamation mark So
Ronaldo did speak out and the same Gary
Neville said he should be sacked
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah likes Ferguson left I
saw not evolution in the club the
progress was Zero nothing changed
surprisingly natural only the pulled
jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which as I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
we see many
things that I'm used to seeing when I
was 20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
well 13 years after a spectacular first
battle United Ronaldo returned to find a
club that had only gone backwards in his
View and that's the real reason he
wanted to do this interview in the first
place he just had enough and he felt he
wasn't getting the respect that his
extraordinary career deserved and all
the fans getting what they deserve for
supporting United week in week out last
season Ronaldo scored 24 goals for a
teaming total turmoil one Premier League
goal more than Harry Kane England's
Captain who is considered one of the top
Strikers in the world right now but
still they blamed Ronaldo his own coach
Eric tenhall disrespected him repeatedly
in public journalists cashed in on the
status for click bait many of the story
is completely untrue Ronaldo soaked all
this up for a long time even though many
of the stories about him were false and
hurtful
and I'm also the lie that he skipped
pre-season training to force a transfer
and in fact his baby daughter was sick
in hospital just months after her twin
brother had tragically died
Ronaldo told me the executives of the
club didn't even believe him
I wonder he felt very little loyalty to
them in return well now this chapter in
his record-breaking career is over many
people have accused me of using Ronaldo
speculating the he must surely regret
ever sitting down with me in fact the
opposite is true he's very happy with
everything about the interview he said
what he wanted to say and he spoke
because he wanted to speak it takes to
be repeatedly this week all good as we
said on Friday when it finally all add
as he's in Doha now in Qatar to Captain
Portugal at the World Cup the future is
great he says that I reckon for him it
probably will be even at 37 he's a mega
star the biggest icon in football
history with half a billion Instagram
followers but that in context 130
million more than his nearest rival
Lionel Messi his rival for everything
we're not as a merchandising monster or
make a fortune whichever Club he signs
for it's still a gold machine too you
don't go from scoring 24 goals last
season to a terrible striker in four or
five months
there's been a lot of knee-jerk reaction
from some United fans I mean he's
trashed his legacy at the club really I
mean he is such a proven performer but
you can see his frustration and you can
and you can identify the issues he goes
back to a facility that's not up to
scratch he goes to a facility where he
wants to be the best where he wants to
maintain standards you say you don't
like the word disrespect I mean he used
that a lot because he feels that if
you're not respected for what you've
achieved in the game and he still
believes he has lots of obvious super
fit as you know you were very fit
actually when you left the England so
you could have played for another five
six years he thinks he's got another two
or three years at least he felt there
was a just a disrespect from everyone
there that had decision making power
yeah well I I think that he is at that
level where he commands respect because
of what he's achieved in the game I do I
agree with you I think he's the greatest
footballer that's played the game he's
he he he he turns the needle that's what
he does and there's a reason why he's
still making headlines four or five days
after the interview because of who he is
there's not many athletes in the world
no that can do that all right and so
there's a reason also why he's in that
position
because of the way that he practices
because of the way that he lives his
life because of the sacrifices that he's
had to make as an individual to achieve
what he's achieved you understand that I
mean I know that you you know for all
your obvious many false uh not as many
as you but for all your money fools uh
everyone we've got one big fault we've
chosen you but even if your colleagues
you know had a problem with you
personally whatever they all said the
same thing you were the first in a last
letter training Ronaldo the same you
never hear anything about his training
regime he's unbelievably self-driven now
that's why I actually agree with
everything that Cristiano has said
purely based on the fact that no coach
if he cares about his player would do
that I agree Mourinho why was Mourinho
amazing why did Lampard Terry drug but
all these guys I mean I did all my rehab
for my achilles at uh um uh Cobham at
Chelsea's training ground why do they
love Mourinho if the team had a bad game
Mourinho made the game about it
thank you was the same all the great
managers I think protect their players
but if I take the players what did you
make of it bro I mean Cristiano Ronaldo
United Legend torching really the club
um what do you think well I think it's
I can see where he's coming from
but he also has to understand that it is
not out at Ferguson anymore it's not
that United and I could see that there
was probably a great sentimental
movement to go back to the club where he
really began where all began and Alex
well you know there's nobody there's
nobody like Alex Fergus and Alex
persuaded him and I was supposed to come
back yeah well thinking well Alan's well
naturally because Alex loves the club
and he's trying to keep the club but the
club has gone through many so many
changes in the last few years now
playing for Juventus and playing for
Real Madrid and their clubs have been in
an incredible they haven't stopped
they're just the top of the league
Manchester United has not been playing
well over the last few years but it's
beginning to get its
it's mojo back and I think it's
unfortunate that this has happened and I
is he entitled to speak out well of
course he's entitled to speak up but but
also you want us to examine exactly
where he's coming from and I think he's
coming from a place where he's saying
you know I I wanted to go back to a
beginning I wanted to go back to that
Glory Days that where when I was a young
boy and I understand he said his heart
ruled his head to it he's not ruled his
head to a degree and in a sense
that's going to be difficult and a
manager who's trying to create a new
club and there's going to be a clash and
I think it's it's it's quite tragic
actually and it's tragic for him but
it's also tragic for the club yeah you
know and I think the club has to be
given a break on this I mean I I do
think it's hard it's clearly hard
because his expectation must have been
huge and especially if Alex persuaded
him to go back that must have been a
huge thing but he's been disappointed
and you can't take away his
disappointment because it is not the
same club that he was at all those years
ago have you ever had a situation in
your career when you've been tempted to
walk out or have you walked out of a a
show a play a TV show anything like that
no no I just I I'm clever enough to
avoid going into those situations have
you seen people do it yeah I've seen
people walk away you know and uh you
know and I've understood why they do it
and it's it's usually complex reasons
when I did it actually well yeah but I
did it because actually when I listened
to Ronaldo I sort of thought yeah it was
he actually comes down to respect I
think it doesn't matter what the job is
if you actually feel disrespected in
your workplace that's right and you feel
you're being forced on another way you
don't want to go down I actually think
there's a certain marriage just saying
actually it's not for me thanks yeah and
I think that's maybe I mean that this I
mean I'm glad the interviews had the the
coverage that it's had in terms of I
mean amazing 50 million is quite
incredible but at the same time I'm
going
um it's rather sad that that's the view
you're going to get because you know I
think and certainly with these kids and
with his family and you know going back
to Manchester is a difficult thing I
think losing the baby in the tragedy
with the twins and one died and one
lived that's got a really good and I
think he wanted a bit more of an arm
wrap yeah and he didn't get it yeah and
and that's it may just really be as
simple as that you can't let you go
without asking about succession one of
my favorite shows ever in the history of
television
you've got a new series coming coming in
the new year can you tell me anything or
do you have to shoot me
piers
I don't have a gun
but if I did
you'd have to be shocked is Logan Roy in
series six well there isn't series six
we're only series four I know that's a
trick question
you know what let's see what happens I
mean in other words does he survive this
series well it's four you're doing now
so there's people yeah Hills about this
series yeah there'll be no problem
there's no death we have to no no no no
none of that and that's all that's all
speculation and nonsense no I mean
there's a lot to be dealt with in terms
of who's going to take over and there's
a lot to be dealt with in terms of the
writers and where they can go with it
see the great thing about Jesse
Armstrong is he doesn't stay too long at
the fair right
because each season has topped the last
season so we have to keep talking it
reminds me of Aaron Sorkin on The West
Wing where the first four seasons were
fantastic then he left and the writing
collapse and the whole thing and that's
what we don't want to happen yeah Tom
Cruise has just made one of the biggest
movies of all time yeah
Maverick it's great have you heard from
him in recent years no not in a while
nothing
what'd you say would you like to have
done you know it is what it is I get it
listen do you get it though I don't
think I would get it in that position I
have to get it you know why because like
I said God's will works in my life good
and bad and I have to accept the both
there's this show that we're doing you
know I've had some difficult stuff in my
life over time and I can remember every
single person that put their hand out
for me yeah and I can remember even more
everyone that disappeared right or just
you just didn't hear from right and
you're so it an extra can be linked to
someone like Tom Cruise from that movie
you want an Oscar for that movie you're
working with him you think he could at
least have maybe just called
I I was also
inflictedly linked to Cameron Crowe I
was linked to James L Brooks but I'm
also linked to people that I'm working
with now I get it but do you get it
because it's like I get it you want to
know the dirt about it but to me no no
I'm not I genuinely am not after any
dirt I guess your thing your response
when I mentioned Tom Cruise is name
actually it looked to me like you were a
bit hurt you hadn't heard from him it's
the thing where anyone that shows you
support is somebody that you're going to
gravitate towards the people in my life
now what do you think about those who
don't the people that are in my eye
watch yourself the people in my life now
uh Joe Callahan who created this
technology for view it uh Danny
Rodriguez who's a crypto entrepreneur to
the nth degree created the show for me
called Tycoon that we're going into
production in did I reach out to you uh
oh no no really no that's two that's two
I can't wait to hear number three I
remember you just the bottle with I've
I've done a few projects with her yeah
not heard a word it's it's one of those
things Pierce where I I gotta be honest
I'm really not off to you I'm not off to
any anything at all from you about it I
just suddenly thought with the two
people I know because I interviewed you
around the time of the butler yeah I
know how big Oprah was and supportive at
the time when things were good same with
Tom Cruise it's just it's interesting to
me that these two superstars when
someone is really going through the
worst time of their life
can't even pick a phone up but is it the
worst time of my life really I mean it
was one of those times that you get
through I think my father's death was
probably a little bit harder right
so it's now I I can't sit and dwell on
that I gotta move forward with the
Positive Pierce